let's go next - why don't we go next to
Caesar from San Antonio
Caesar what's going on hello hey how are
you okay yeah yeah um yeah my question I
want to say is would is to deal with all
these insane pseudo-intellectual in
backward groups such as for example
anti-vaccine movement in cells McDowell
Flat Earth theory and all these crazy
groups are just not only increasing but
online but also entering the mainstream
public of opinion well so let's see I
mean what are they increasing I don't
know if they're increasing or if they're
just louder you know like for example I
don't know that Donald Trump has created
more white nationalists but he's
definitely embolden them so that we hear
more from them so I don't like what what
evidence do you have that these beliefs
are actually increasing I'm not saying
you're wrong I'm just asking are they
actually increasing or are we just
hearing from them more yeah I think
we're just hearing more from them
because a few years ago I didn't I
didn't even know that that's some of the
stuff even existed I mean I didn't know
that that insult even existed or
flatters people hold on Caesar I mean
certainly if even if someone's not
called an N cell you knew there were
people who weren't able to find others
to have sex with right like you knew
that that was a thing not everybody is
able to do that yeah I mean okay so now
it has a name but those people have been
around for a long time yeah but lately
people are like for example with himself
I didn't know that people actually went
on crazy shootings or hurt people just
because they can't get laid
okay well all right well now we're
starting to get into some more specific
dynamics but certainly the idea of if
not for being unable to get laid as you
lay it out we know that people for a
very long time are driven to commit acts
of violence because they are sort of
disaffected by society in a general way
right yeah that's what I'm talking I
think that's just kind of strange that
somebody would do that
okay well I mean you may find its me I
don't know that it's new I mean here
here's what I think the more important
question which is the pseudo
intellectualism that you talked about
that's really the danger for me because
there's always been a group of people
that just isn't really interested in
learning or in knowing stuff and it's
just sort of like okay that's always
gonna be around but the danger to me is
the pseudo intellectuals who think that
when they read these kind of bluff
political pop books like a book by you
know Laura Ingraham or Tucker Carlson or
whatever and they think that they're
educated in some way and then are like
well equipped to participate in
discussions about the future of the
United States and what policy should be
I think that that's the danger the
people that think that they are informed
and in reality they're not they're not
seriously informed about issues and then
they vote and they have an impact that's
really the concern for me yeah I know
but like for example what I was talking
about the anti-vaccine woman again
seriously people need to learn to
vaccinate already because we don't need
the measles or or even smallpox coming
back obviously yeah I mean we don't I
mean seriously this idea that vaccines
cause autism is nonsense
yes have been literally debunked and the
guy who pushed it was lost his medical
license Caeser basically agree with you
really appreciate the call thank you all
right take care
great to hear from Ceaser